watch this video to master
ushiro yoko kami the backside roll
hi guys i'm mihai dobroka from yokohama
aikidojo
in the previous video we saw ushirokami
backroll
in actual practice you may need some
more distance between you and your
opponent before attacking again
so as a next step i recommend you to
learn ushiro
yoko kami the backside role of aikido
as a preparation to get the feeling that
your body is rolling from one side to
the other
i recommend you to lie down
yes have both of your feet on one side
and move them to the other one like this
the upper one is always extended
okay after this you can sit one knee up
one knee down for ushi okay me we went
we went backwards
now for usual uh yoko kami the side roll
the upper body goes to the side and
you're gonna roll
uh over your hips legs move
and yeah you're gonna sit up facing the
opposite direction
keep your leg straight in the air
okay after this you can start it from
kneeling as a second step
have a straight posture make sure that
you once
sit on your ankle it can be dangerous
move your foot away sit on the mat and
everything else goes just like before
if you have any difficulties with
sitting up
it can be because your feet are too
close so make sure that when you roll
you're stretching your foot in the
direction that you are moving
so it's gonna be easier to kneel up
and later to stand up okay next step
from hammy standing position i'm gonna
kneel down
and sit and just like before from
humming
to hand me make sure that your body is
straight good posture
and to the side
in actual practice we usually start the
ukami from the front leg
which is closer to the partner so it's
good to practice this ukami like this
step back kneel
and after you stand up you have to turn
backwards where your partner
actually is other side
you can stand up just like before and
pivot
and pivot or another way that i
personally prefer to do
is something like this i put my toes
close together
i'm in this toe crunch position so it's
easier
faster to turn so you can reduce the
time
when you are showing your back to your
partner
and turn instantly and stand up
as a more advanced exercise it's good to
practice that your body is actually
falling backwards
so the ukemi is going to look like this
i'm standing naturally stretching back
first
and try to get the feeling that my i'm
unbalanced and i'm actually falling
backwards
and start looking from there
yeah stretching
something like this let's take a look at
some applications
first from category sumitoshi previously
we learned ushirokamin
which was like this
so when you stand up here the distance
is too close
that's why it's better to use in actual
practice that you shrug yokocami
so you can get far enough before
attacking again
okay next one ko kyo
[Music]
okay same side okay
here the flexibility in the movement is
important
i try to stay connected and feel
what's going on through the connection
feel it with your whole body
your center absorb your partner's power
and start the interview when you
actually reach
spoiler alert we are going to make a
video on static and
dynamic flexibility very soon now from
category shihonega
and idi minaga
thank you for watching if you like this
video please give it a thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe see you in
the next video
you